jacques chirac était président 98 comme
on l'a dit lorsque les bleus ont
remporté leur première coupe du monde il
avait alors embrassé le crâne de fabien
barthez se dévouent second set quand il
rentrait investir alors on le voit avec
le maillot 23e joueur enfin à fond les
gamelles fabien verrai je te claque la
bise et nous c'était de sortir la balle
en finale c'était sortir la bouteille de
champagne arroser le président c'était
devenu à nos potes
là
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vous avez négligé minibus à
ça c'est un c'est un grand grand grand
moment d'ailleurs j'aimerais est ce que
vous l'avez on peut pas re voir
l'extrait qu'on a mis dans touche pas à
mon poste compte il dit le nom des
joueurs de l'équipe de 1,8 à ça c'est
exceptionnel sarsgaard
[Applaudissements]
bright
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
syrie
le bon filon
eh ben ils savent quand il est à côté de
la plaque ça reste sympathique non mais
c'est ça bon c'est vrai parce
qu'aujourd'hui un autre paysan qui se
fait il fait ça il se chiffre à gaza
derrière toujours agacé alors